et maintenant
etienne daho
beaucoup
non bien il ya un truc que je me demande
c'est un truc que je me demande depuis
des années
c'est ça la cantèle dit tiens le bien je
tiens bien vous aussi puisque méline est
ce qu'on peut apporter le porte voix
parce que comme daoud quelqu'un qui a
pas une voix énorme donc etienne tu sais
comment ça marche
voilà si tu as besoin voilà je marche
pas à ces marches ligue 2 2 oui très
bien
oui j'ai entendu dire que je deviens un
peu chaud ici et là parce que le 1er
mars sera mis en vente en un cd qui
s'appelle sortir ce soir best of live et
on va en écouter les meilleurs moments
dj
et
ce mois
week end
afin de coincer
manqué
bocal
je
le feu d'un dut
j'ai tendu
dus à la
le teint foncé
c'est
entrée
tourner
tôt ou tard c
comment le sang
que je
[ __ ] d'ennui
le
et qui
g
je fais tourner la tête
au manège à moi
c'est toi je suis toujours à la 17e
quand je me tiens dans tes bras
j'ai tout ici
g
jusqu'au bout
agitez bon cap les
hambourg comme avant
je viens
je passais
bethany d'un crime hors jeu talent
sur le bout de
on pressent le pas sont tendues
son esprit la rejeter
bon voilà
moussa
ça c'est sur le cd bonus track google le
titres cdc sortir ce soir
la version 0 5
etienne daho tour nouveau cd alors bien
chasser le chai des normales en plus les
une édition limitée avec des cd bonus 1
il ya six titres et puis le 15 mars y
ait un dvd qui s'appellerait évolution
tour l'intégrale du concert on va
regarder à quoi ça ressemble les
regarder votre caméra jeu rien à dire
vous regardez votre caméra le chef des
affaires etienne c'est dire manito serge
mellal tous serge lama magnéto serge
voilà